so those are the numbers as of tonight
the question is what happens next well
yesterday a piece the New York Times
asked that s would appear to be a pretty
straightforward question when will New
York City reach the peak of its outbreak
New York City of course being the place
with the most cases in this country and
you'd think that epidemiologists could
answer that question with some precision
but as it turns out no they can't
Governor Andrew Cuomo predicted the peak
will come this week the head of New York
Presbyterian Hospital predicted April
15th the state's health commissioner
meanwhile thought late April or maybe
early May the predictions differed by up
to a full month at a time when New
Yorkers quarantine and people are still
dying that is a very big range of
answers Howard Markel a physician
professor at the University of Michigan
summed up the current state of knowledge
this way quote in reality we don't know
know we don't know in fact a close look
at the data suggests the peak of the
epidemic in New York may have already
passed five days ago on April 2nd 1420
seven people were hospitalized for
coronavirus in New York it's the highest
number so far recorded the next day that
total dropped to 1095 and then on Sunday
it fell to only 358 in the last two days
new hospitalizations have ticked up once
again but they're still far below last
Thursday's peak if this trend holds we
don't know that it will but if it does
the worst may already be over from New
York all of this has come as a surprise
to our public health authorities and a
welcome surprise to those of us watching
the Institute for Health metrics and
evaluation the IHM E is a well-regarded
Research Center run from the University
of Washington the IHM E has produced
details predictions charting the
expected course of this epidemic here in
the United States as well as in other
countries their model has done perhaps
more than any other piece of academic
research to shape our response to the
coronavirus crisis so how accurate has
that model been here are some numbers
initially the IHM e predicted that on
April 4th the state of New York would
require 65,000 hospital beds to handle
infected patients the low-end estimate
of what the state would need was nearly
48 thousand beds in fact on April 4th
New York had fewer than 16,000
hospitalizations for coronavirus and
many other states fell far below the
models projections as well many states
over the weekend the IHM II updated its
model its projections across the country
have been scaled back dramatically and
yet they are still significantly
overstated for example today which is
April 7th the updated ihe me model
predicts that New York will need 25,000
hospital beds as of this morning the
real number was just under 17,500 the
new model also predicted that as of
today almost 6600 people would be in
intensive care and the actual number is
just under 4,600 in Florida the new
model predicted 4,000 people would be
hospitalized the reality the floor
tonight is that not even 2,000 are and
it wasn't just Florida and New York the
I heme got it wrong in state after state
after state by the way for America this
is great news and we should celebrate it
it's much better than we thought though
unfortunately the question of total
deaths the model has been more accurate
though it still tends to overshoot for
example yesterday the I heme predicted
784 deaths for New York the state
finished the day with about 600 for the
entire country the model predicts about
2,000 deaths today and sadly it seems
like we'll finish somewhere around that
number but that may not be the whole
story there is nuance within those
numbers as there always is in social
science for many years the CDC has
tracked the total number of Americans
who die every week from pneumonia for
the last few weeks that number has come
in far lower than at the same moment in
previous years how could that be
well it seems entirely possible that
doctors are classifying conventional
pneumonia deaths as kovat 19 deaths that
would mean this epidemic is being
credited for thousands of deaths that
would have occurred if the virus never
appeared here we don't know that for
certain but it's certainly worth
considering something is skewing those
numbers nor do we know exactly why the
model predicted so many more
hospitalizations than we have actually
had now you will hear people say you're
hearing them say now that this is
evidence that the shutdown's and social
distancing must be working but not so
fast those measures were built into the
model in the first place they've already
been taken into account and we are still
doing far better than what
epidemiologists believed was the best
case scenario so the question is and
it's essential question as we move
forward
how did this happen well it's possible
the virus is just less deadly than we
feared it was or it's less likely to
send people to the hospital
maybe it spreads less easily than we
thought it did maybe it spreads more
easily than we thought it did and the
number of asymptomatic carriers is
higher than we knew all of those are
reasonable theories we have no idea
which one could be true then there's
this in a new draft paper MIT economist
Jeffrey Harris suggests that Americans
are following social distancing
guidelines more effectively than
authorities ever imagined they would and
that's another potential explanation
whatever's happening this is epidemic
appears to be doing less damage than
anticipated and it's receding more
quickly not so long ago some of our
leaders seemed on the verge of panic on
March 24th for example Governor Cuomo of
New York descended into a state of
frenzy during his daily press conference
Cuomo dismissed the federal assistance
New York had received as grossly
inefficient tens of thousands of
innocent New Yorkers were going to die
he said they will choke to death while
doctors do nothing to help them watch
FEMA says were sending 400 Grantha
laters really what am I gonna what am I
going to do with 400 ventilators when I
need 30,000 you picked the 26 thousand
people who are going to die because you
only sent 400 ventilators you pick the
people who are going to die it was
effective theater but it was awful what
a horrifying thought that was as
recently as last Friday April 3rd
Governor Cuomo was threatened to use the
National Guard to seize ventilators from
facilities upstate that's how badly New
York needed them except it didn't need
them as it turned out New York has many
more beds and ventilators than it needs
equipment that's the protective
equipment ventilators where we are we
are stretching and moving but every
hospital has what they need today
so miscalculations like the ones you
just saw played out across the country
in state after state on March 14th for
example the governor of Oregon Kate
Brown warned that her state 688
ventilators wouldn't be nearly enough to
handle the coming surge of coronavirus
cases it turns out she got it backward
Oregon had more ventilators than it
needed
so in April 4th Governor Brown shipped
50 of the machines to New York which
based on current trends may not need
them either now once again we ought to
celebrate all of this fewer
hospitalizations are a godsend for this
country and as awful as this epidemic
has been and will be at least so far it
hasn't been the disaster that we feared
our health care system hasn't collapsed
that was the key concern except in a
handful of places really it hasn't come
very close patients are not dying alone
in the hallways of emergency rooms with
physicians too overwhelmed to treat them
that was the concern it happens in other
countries it's not happening here thank
God for that all of this means that the
short-term crisis the ones that we
worried about so fervently in which
pressure on hospitals grew so
exponentially day by day with no end in
sight that short-term crisis may have
passed we'll see but it looks like it
may have now it's time to look ahead if
the virus is doing less systemic damage
to our system than expected then
presumably we can begin to consider how
to improve the lives of the rest the
countless Americans who've been
grievously hurt by this by our response
to this how do we get 17 million of our
most vulnerable citizens back to work
that's our task other countries are
already hard at work doing it adjusted
for population Denmark's Crona virus
outbreak has been almost precisely as
severe as ours has been here in the US
in Denmark schools and daycare centres
are scheduled to open next week the
government plans to roll back more
restrictions on May 10th the outbreak in
Austria has also been similar in scope
to America per capita there the
government plans to let small stores
reopen April 14th followed by large
stores on May 1st and then potentially
restaurants and schools in the middle of
May so that's what they're doing we're
not doing that here we're not even
talking about doing it because we're not
allowed to any discussion of how we
might transition out of the shutdown
back into normal life for some reason
has become taboo in this country go
ahead and raise the question you'll find
yourself denounced as a tool of wall
street who doesn't care about human life
often denounced by pro-choice activists
we're happy to accept cash from
corporate America but the layers of
irony are of course bottomless but we
shouldn't be surprised by any of this
this is what happens when public debate
healthy public debate is replaced by
and mindless partisans on social media
define the terms of allowable
conversation as they have and so we plod
forward as if the flawed models weren't
flawed at all is if the reality of what
is actually happening in our hospitals
should play no role at all in the
decisions we make going forward dr.
Anthony Fauci has announced for example
that Americans must brace for 18 months
of shutdowns at the absolute minimum and
if a vaccine isn't found it could go on
forever if back to normal means acting
like there never was a coronavirus
problem I don't think that's gonna
happen until we do have a situation
where you can completely protect the
population if you want to get to pre
corona virus you know that might not
ever happen in the sense of the the fact
that the threat is there so life may
never return to normal in this country
we may never regain what we've lost
you're hearing a lot of people say that
all of a sudden it's becoming a species
of conventional wisdom on MSNBC last
night where conventional wisdom often is
born
UPenn professor Zeke Emanuel explained
that America may be shuttered for 18
months at least
realistically kovat 19 will be here for
the next 18 months or more we will not
be able to return to normalcy until we
find a vaccine or effective medications
I know that's dreadful news to hear how
are people supposed to find work if this
goes on in some form for a year and a
half is all that economic pain worth
trying to stop kovat 19 the truth is we
have no choice if we prematurely end
that physical distancing and the other
measures keeping it at bay deaths could
skyrocket into the hundreds of thousands
if not a million we cannot return to
normal until there's a vaccine
conferences concerts sporting events
religious services dinner in a
restaurant none of that will resume
until we find a vaccine a treatment or a
cure you can't go to church until we
have a vaccine the truth is we have no
choice
heard that before that's a familiar
phrase in Washington it ought to make
you nervous
do what I say follow my orders without
question or complaint or a million
people will die the oceans will rise the
polar bears will perish the human race
itself will go extinct okay
maybe these are smart people we should
hear them out but these are also big
decisions history changing decisions
with consequences we can't even begin to
anticipate this far out before we go
ahead and alter our lives and our
country forever it is fair to ask about
the numbers their numbers the ones we
acted on the first time that turned out
to be completely wrong how'd they screw
that up so thoroughly that is a fair
question if they can answer that
question answer it slowly rationally in
a way that makes sense and suggests a
deeper humility going forward as they
make more decisions then that's adequate
that's enough they're allowed to make
more public policy decisions but if they
can't answer that question if they
dissemble or dodge or attack the people
who asked it then you know they are
disqualified forever from influencing
our lives let's see if they can do it
they should